welcome to this video playing dr. Zhang
LUN nice opponent so what are we going
to do I will do something else don't
want way again just for for the sake of
variety maybe try the three-door see
what he's doing against that 92 ok
that's an interesting way to play yeah I
think I think you can play be five in
this position let's try that I think
that's possible 95 94 if he takes Knight
e5 does even though they three meet
threatened so I get them and get a quick
han caido n so let's see if he goes just
you can just castle probably be 495 ok
so here I was thinking c6 with them
somewhat if he takes with the somewhat
Sicilian like structure really look so
like a Sicilian ok before here or not
maybe i can i can first develop ok so
interesting can also yeah I have before
I can maybe also take not sure about it
but ok I should think like ages about it
so here do I take and if i take with
what not very familiar with this
position type I have a bad feeling about
taking with the bishop it weakens the
light squares quite considerably yeah
not sure I'm really not sure about it
maybe I'm wrong here the bishop on b7 is
also not looking super great ok sure I
can go to a six it's maybe not such a
bad place for the bishop
this a 5 horn is some might also be
controversial at some point if we if we
can a ticket let's plug what about d3 a
b3 here p 3 p 3 it takes 95-93 coming
this stuff okay let's do it
that makes it tries to use the the
bishop here really I'm not quite sure
what is responses to be honest I mean a
good response
and frightening night d three here and
take here okay let's let's just let's
just do that and consider afterwards it
really should be just good for black and
i will pick a yoke 21 not seeing a
direct refutation of that can go back to
the three but it's their way to really
punish him here if he go somewhere else
i take e to and everyone which is just
just winning material so i was a bit
surprised that he that he took time here
um here it's this some way to to really
do something great
I don't I don't see anything right here
to be honest
I mean it looks nice somehow for me but
I don't I don't see any any way forward
go back here but every don't see how to
use this in any way my bishop only seven
is not playing i don't i don't see a
good continuation yeah i was looking 95
practices really also just a repetition
quincy eight maybe somehow i really
don't know with them some possible ideas
of Quincy five it's maybe an idea Quincy
five is a double attack on f 2 and a 3
it's quite that should be a problem
really for white
it was a little additional idea of
quincy aid the rookie is unprotected and
whites position was uncomfortable
definitely yeah this is this is really
losing huge chunks of material him
I don't see a move really i will just
take up two other resins yeah yeah i
blundered them it wasn't really
comfortable anyway I think when he after
be three it looks quite okay right yeah
well the computer is just giving be
three with a big edge from locking the
applicator almost upon and after the
capture its really really nice but here
here I didn't really found didn't really
find something great as spender but I
took okay this is I think it's not
necessary strictly but but why not I was
taking he went here and now back here
and f5 now is what the computer
suggesting f5 why f5 okay okay it it
introduces or Bishop g5 also should be
seems to be good yeah we'll just just
continue to play in a way which was also
my idea with Queen CA but he's got
Bishop before which I didn't really
consider at all Bishop before hmm and
before I it is okay yeah I look that
we've totally okay it's not like fatal
yeah this is not not so great for wide
actually because i still have have those
ideas and trapping it and so on but
still a should have he should have done
that this is also interested check
very hard for a human to consider such a
move yeah I mean this is justice was
just blundering blundering the house
yeah with this this double check why
Tess has no way to save himself okay
nice win against suggests legend but it
was really more like her his loss them i
win okay thanks for watching